-Good morning, everyone.
We're going to start this
morning with a blessing
by Jonathan Perry.
-[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Creator, we want to say thank
you for the great minds that
have gathered here today
to share their knowledge
and to help bring indigenous
issues and indigenous
people to the forefront and
to a great future for all
of our people, for opportunities
for sharing and opening
our hearts and our minds, for
understanding and awareness
and respect.
We want to say thank you
to all of the families
and all of the
people who sacrificed
for us to be here today.
We want to say thank
you to our ancestors,
thank you to all the beings
that have helped us to achieve
our goals, who sustain us,
nourish us, protect us,
teach us, and care for
us every single day.
We want to send our
blessings and prayers out
to those who are
sick and who need
our prayers or our
thoughts or our well
wishes at this time, all
of those that were not
able to attend this gathering or
were not able to travel with us
or are not able to be
here in some fashion.
I'd like to offer an
honor song for all of you
and all of your
families at this time.
[NATIVE AMERICAN SINGING]
I want to say thank you for
coming to our territory.
Thank you for joining
us in what is considered
to be Wampanoag Nipmuc
Massachusetts territory,
this area.
This was, of course,
a thoroughfare
for all of our people
both by the sea and land.
And we have over
12,000 years, anyway,
scientifically
proven success here.
So we hope to revisit those
many, many years of success.
And I think we'll do well.
I just want to do
one more quick song,
and I'd like to ask all
of you to help me with it.
This is very specifically
a Wampanoag song.
And normally we
would join hands,
one hand to the back of the
shoulder on the heart side
all the way around.
But if you can, if
you can't, you can't.
That's fine.
But I need some
help singing this.
It's very easy.
So just join in as you can.
[NATIVE AMERICAN SINGING]
-Thank you so much, Jonathan.
That was a very beautiful
way to start today
on a very beautiful spring day.
So good morning.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I'm delighted to welcome
you to today's conference,
Native Peoples, Native Politics.
We are very proud to
co-sponsor this conference
with the Harvard University
Native American Program, or at
is as it is commonly known
in these parts, HUNAP.
I want to thank Jonathan Perry
for his wonderful opening
blessing in tribute to
the people who walked
this ground long before us.
I'd also like to thank
Shelly Lowe, the Executive
Director of HUNAP, Dan
Carpenter, the Faculty
Director of the Social Sciences
program here at Radcliffe,
and Maggie McKinley, Climenko
Fellow at the Harvard Law
School, for their leadership
in planning today's conference.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe fosters
interdisciplinary inquiry
into important and
multifaceted subjects.
We bring leading
thinkers together
to investigate new
questions, and we
are committed to sharing
that emerging knowledge
with the broader community
through public events
like this one today
and many others.
Coming up on Tuesday,
May 10, we will
launch the Kim and Judy
Davis Lecture Series here
in the Knafel Center.
Professor Diana Mutz of the
University of Pennsylvania
will deliver the
inaugural Davis Lecture
about public opinion
toward globalization.
And you have a card to
remind you on your seat.
Mutz's talk will
take a sharp look
at the free trade controversy.
Her topic could
not be more timely
as we watch
presidential candidates
in both political
parties grapple
with this volatile
issue and assess
its impact on the lives
of American producers
and consumers.
So I hope to see you
here with us on May 10.
We conclude our
academic programming
for the year with
Radcliffe Day on May 27,
when we bestow the Radcliffe
Medal on Janet Yellen, Chair
of the Federal Reserve.
We will celebrate Yellen's
ideals and intellect
with a morning panel
that's entitled
Building an Economy for
Prosperity and Equality.
A lunchtime program will feature
personal remarks about Yellen
by former Fed
Chair Ben Bernanke,
followed by a conversation
between Harvard
Professor of Economics Greg
Makiw and Yellen herself.
So even if you can't
join us in person,
you can tune in to the live
stream of the whole day
on our website on May 27,
or you can watch it later
when it is posted as a
video on our website.
At Radcliffe we also
help focus attention
on important topics
of broad interest
that cross many Harvard schools,
fields, and disciplines.
This year, in
partnership with HUNAP,
we have hosted a
rich set of programs
centered on native and
indigenous peoples.
Let me give you just
a few examples of what
our thematic year has produced.
Fellows in our
fellowship program
have worked on projects related
to Native American history,
rights, and culture.
The Schlesinger Library
hosted an edit-a-thon
to improve and increase
Wikipedia entries
on native an indigenous women.
A poet and a playwright
gave public performances.
And an exhibition of the
photographs of Matika Wilbur
is currently on display in
the Johnson-Kulukundis Family
Gallery in Byerly Hall,
which is just two doors down.
It will remain up
until May 28, so please
be sure to visit this wonderful
exhibition during the break
today at lunch, or in
the short periods we have
in the morning
and the afternoon,
or sometime in the next month.
This stimulating and
varied body of work
related to native and
indigenous peoples
has benefited the entire
Harvard community.
Next year some of
our programming
will address another
theme, this time the issue
of urbanism, historically,
humanistically,
and as a worldwide phenomenon.
For the following
two years we will
investigate many different
aspects of citizenship.
The timing will correspond with
one significant anniversary,
the 150th anniversary of
the 14th Amendment, which
extended citizenship
to African Americans.
And that comes in 2018.
And we will anticipate a
second major milestone,
the 100th anniversary of the
19th Amendment giving women
the right to vote.
And that would be 2020.
The Native and Indigenous
Peoples Initiative
has enjoyed robust support
from Provost Alan Garber
and has been nurtured by many
Radcliffe staff, especially
Rebecca Wasserman
and her team, as well
as faculty,
departments, and centers
all across the university.
Today's conference is
a fitting culmination
to those collaborative efforts.
A quick glance at the
speakers on today's program
demonstrates the breadth
of partnerships that have
made this conference possible.
Before today is out we will
hear from lawyers, community
leaders, artists, policymakers,
anthropologists, activists,
the 67th president of the
Seneca Nation, and even a CEO.
This conference has brought
together an even broader range
of people in today's audience.
That's you.
You are sitting among painters
and public health advocates,
consultants and clergy members,
teachers and tribal members.
You have come from
all over New England
and as far afield as Quebec,
North Dakota, and Arizona,
as well as from
Harvard's many schools.
Today's program will bring
together even more people
virtually.
Students in the
state of Washington
and a member of Ontario's
Ministry of Aboriginals
Affairs, among many
others, have written to us
to say that they plan to tune in
to the simulcast online today.
And I'm sure that
many more viewers
will watch the video on our
website in the months and years
ahead.
It is fitting that today's
conference on native peoples
and politics has gathered
so many different people
in conversation
with one another,
because the practice
of politics inevitably
brings vastly
different individuals
and groups with
multiple priorities
and conflicting agendas
into common conversation,
and sometimes combat.
Given where we are in this
year's election cycle,
it can seem like
politics consists solely
of delegate counts and
convention countdowns.
But if we reduce
politics to nothing
more than election
hoopla, we oversimplify
what it really means.
In fact, the equation
of politics with voting
is a fairly recent phenomenon.
For much of human
existence, voting
as we understand it today
in our democratic society
has not existed.
Even when it has,
participation has usually
been restricted to a very
small minority of the world's
total population.
In reality, the definition of
politics changes over time,
and it is shaped in unique
ways by different societies
and different cultures.
People have acted
politically across the globe
and throughout human
history, but they
have done so in many other
ways than casting ballots.
I'm an historian of the
20th century United States.
In the time and
place that I study,
universal suffrage was
officially the law of the land.
But in my research
over the years,
I have found that voting
was not the only or even
the most common way that
Americans acted politically.
Let me remind you of just
a handful of other ways
that ordinary people
advocated for their rights
and for the kind of just
society that they desired.
In the 1930s, working
class Americans
organized into
industrial labor unions
to demand a larger share of the
wealth their labor had helped
to create, to influence
their working conditions,
and to exert more control
over how they allocated time
in their own lives.
From the 1940s
through the 1960s,
household members and
homemakers took to the streets
to assert their
power as consumers,
participating in
boycotts and petitioning
against high
prices, and lobbying
for greater protections
against unsafe and exploitative
products.
In the 1950s and 1960s,
African Americans
mobilized with strategies
ranging from restaurants
sit-ins to protest marches
to demand their equal rights
as citizens, creating a
civil rights movement that
would inspire similar claims by
the American Indian movement,
feminists, and gay
rights activists.
Beginning in the 1970s,
political activists
on the conservative
right from anti-taxers
to anti-abortion demonstrators,
undertook similar actions
to promote their causes.
In all of these cases
and more, Americans
were acting politically.
In sum, today's conference is
part of a broader conception
of political participation
that goes beyond what
happens in the voting booth.
As we dig deeply into
the multiple ways
that Native Americans
have registered
their political
will, we will also
be probing the very
wide range of voices
speaking within those
native communities.
We will surely see that there
is not one conversation nor one
uniform point of view.
I personally look forward to
a day of learning and gaining
new insight and inspiration.
So let me tell you a little
bit about how today will work.
This morning we
will have two panels
before we break for lunch.
After lunch there'll be a
keynote address and then
a final panel.
Each panel will conclude with
a question and answer session.
If you would like
to ask a question,
please step into
the center aisle,
where we will have
set up a microphone,
and when you come
to the mic, we ask
that you identify yourself
and state your question.
And finally, I hope
you will join us
at a concluding reception which
will be held in Fay House right
next door, where we can
continue our conversations.
Now I'd like to hand things
over to Professor Dan Carpenter.
Dan is the Director of the
Social Sciences Program
here at the Radcliffe Institute,
the Allie S. Freed Professor
of Government at
Harvard University,
and a member of the Provost
Advisory Council on Native
and Indigenous Issues.
He is a political
scientist who specializes
in public bureaucracies and
governmental regulation.
He also studies diverse ways in
which individuals participate
politically, what he calls
the performance of politics.
Dan's research has
focused most intensively
on petitioning among
groups often marginalized
and disenfranchised throughout
much of American history,
such as African Americans,
women, and Native Americans.
So please join me
in thanking Dan
for his hard work organizing
today's conference,
and help me welcome
him to the podium.
Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you very much, LIZ.
I want to begin following
Jonathan Perry by acknowledging
the Wampanoag Nipmuc
Massachusetts peoples on whose
lands we gather today.
Today's conference is both a
culmination and a beginning.
Let me start with
the culmination part,
keeping in mind
tomorrow's HUNAP pow wow
will continue this
important celebration.
Three years ago
Radcliffe began thinking
about appropriate themes
for the set of events
that would occur over
a one to one and 1/2
year period that coincides
with today's conference.
And Radcliffe has embarked upon
this series of conversations
and events, the
indigenous peoples theme,
not because the Institute
has a particular expertise
in this area, but because
Radcliffe, and Harvard more
generally, have clear needs
and obligations to enrich
our dialogue on native issues.
A university is a
conversation of a sort,
a highly bureaucratized
conversation,
to be sure, but a vital
dialogue nonetheless.
And it is vital to
the future of Harvard,
and in deep consistency
with Harvard's native past,
that the voice of Native
American and indigenous peoples
be amplified and strengthened.
And it is with thanks to HUNAP
and associated Native Studies
leaders at Harvard at this
process has been renewing.
And we at Radcliffe are
pleased and honored to play
a collaborative part in
this larger and much longer
term dialogue.
We started in the fall of 2014
with Anishinabe poet Gerald
Vizenor, who gave
a poetry reading
and gave thoughtful remarks
on the meaning and intention
of his concept of survivance.
Professor Angela Riley of
UCLA and a Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court of
the Citizen Potawatomi
Nation of Oklahoma,
visited Harvard Law School
to give a lecture on
indigeneity and law.
Professor Ned Blackhawk of
Yale came in November, 2014
and gave reflections
on the Sand Creek
Massacre and its many cultural
and historical legacies.
This academic year we've
been privileged to be joined
by two Native American
Radcliffe Fellows, Kristiana
Kahakauwila, and Alyssa Mt.
Pleasant.
Professor Kahakauwila just
this Wednesday afternoon
gave a wonderful reading from
her novel To Weave with Water.
Professor Mt.
Pleasant has been working on
her study of the Buffalo Creek
reservation and gave an
inspiring lecture in the fall.
Alyssa and Tiana
have both honored
and enriched us with their
daily presence, their meetings
with students,
staff, and faculty,
and other Radcliffe Fellows.
A third fellow, Carol
Armitage, has also
been exploring themes
and indigeneity
in her choreographic work,
and we thank all of them
for their citizenship.
In January we held a workshop
on the university and indigenous
dispossession, where we learned
what other universities have
been doing to confront
their own relationship
to indigenous peoples, and
we learned of rich models
for Harvard to emulate.
And I'm proud to announce
that the Radcliffe Institute,
in collaboration with HUNAP,
the Harvard University Native
American Program, and the
Yale Indian Papers Project,
and supported by the
Mashpee Wampanoag,
the Nipmuc, the Wampanoag
tribe of Gay Head Aquinna,
and the Mohegan Tribe,
has received a $275,000
grant from the Council on
Library and Information
Resources, CLIR, to digitize
more than 4,000 petitions by
and concerning Native Americans
in the Massachusetts archives
of the Commonwealth.
Collaborative meetings
with tribes for this work
are underway this spring, and
digitization will begin soon.
And of course, just
last night Matika Wilbur
offered a beautiful
presentation,
opening up her photographic
exhibition, Seeds of Culture:
The Portraits and Stories
of Native American Women.
What unites so many
of these events
forms the theme and title
of today's conference,
Native Peoples, Native Politics.
In the face of
massive dispossession,
structural racism, how
have native peoples
performed what Gerald
Vizenor calls survivance?
How have they done
political work in doing so?
How have they endeavored to
tell alternative stories?
How have they drawn upon law,
treaties, and other resources?
How have they formed
alliances and coalitions
to defend their
sovereignty and dignity
in the face of
institutionalized erosion,
organized assault?
In talking with Native
American leaders and citizens
we learn that so much of native
politics and empowerment,
as Liz Cohen just remarked,
occurs outside the ballot
box, which is not at all to
say that voting rights are
unimportant.
Quite the opposite is
they are under attack
throughout the land,
including in Indian country.
But it is to say that
Native Americans have often
been denied voting rights,
and where they have had them,
they have often composed
a numerical minority
of the electorate.
Tools of law, treaty
making and monitoring,
retelling and reframing
stories, building alliances
and coalitions, resisting,
blogging, protesting, making
art and politics, and
yes, voting, all of these
are political and cultural
acts, not just political acts.
But we should never forget the
deeply political dimensions
of these acts.
And what you will hear
today are four panels
and a keynote address, five
successive conversations,
if you will, on what
native politics means,
how it is taking shape, and
how native authors, artists,
filmmakers, actors,
scholars, and others view
the political and empowerment
dimensions of their work.
On to beginnings.
As we look forward
to Harvard's future
and to Radcliffe's,
it is vital to ensure
that our discussions
include and incorporate
native and indigenous
perspectives in the themes
we address, including in
citizenship and urbanism,
in the years to come,
and that, again, we
continue to amplify native
presences and native voices
on Harvard's campus.
But let me pause with
a sobering statistic.
Just two weeks ago,
Harvard's Office
for the Vice Provost of Faculty
Development and Diversity
released its report
entitled Ten-Year Trends
in Ladder Faculty.
And in that report, the
office remarks that, quote,
and I quote, "We still
need to make more progress,
as we have only 60 ladder
faculty who are black,
62 latter faculty
who are Latino,
and none who are
Native American."
Let me repeat that.
60 African American
ladder faculty,
and by ladder I mean tenure
track, 62 Latino ladder
faculty, zero Native
American ladder faculty.
And this report comes
in the same year
that Northwestern, Yale,
and other universities
are moving forward
with plans to hire
several native faculty
each, as well as faculty
in Native Studies departments,
which of course do not
exist here.
And it comes at a time when
Harvard's peer Dartmouth, whose
charter dedicates it,
like Harvard's does,
to the education of
Native American youth,
has native faculty in
several different departments
across this college.
This report comes
to us in the middle
of a presidential campaign,
one that Dean Cohen alluded to,
which, among other things,
has given us two competing
aspirations that you've
heard of recently,
one of making
America great again,
and another of making
America whole again.
I'm not going to tip my hand
as to my intended voting
patterns in the
fall, but I do prefer
the latter of
those formulations,
making whole to making great.
And just this last week
another round of reverberations
of those phrases, making
whole and making great,
has made me think, what is it
for a university to be great?
And what is it for a
university to be whole?
On the latter of those
questions, wholeness,
I would not presume to know
an answer to what adds up,
to what things jointly
and together suffice
to make a university whole.
But I can say this.
The richness of the dialogue
we have witnessed this year
between HUNAP and Radcliffe
in observing the heroic work
that Dennis Norman,
Shelly Lowe, Jason
Packineau, and the
whole HUNAP community
and Harvard's native student
community, we can say
that Harvard can never be whole
without its indigenous peoples,
without its indigenous history
fully told and explored,
and that Harvard can never
be whole until its
indigenous family
is included fully on
its ladder faculty.
Beyond this, no university
pretending to be great or whole
can claim to honor diversity
and inclusion while excluding
native peoples, native
peoples who are represented
in the very charter whose
accompanying funds saved
Harvard from insolvency in 1650,
excluding those native people
from its ladder faculty.
So before turning
to today's panel,
and speaking for myself
only, a white man in alliance
with my native
sisters and brothers,
let me outline a vision,
sketched in a petition,
if you will, to make Harvard
whole in the coming years,
that Harvard bring
Native Americans
to its tenured
faculty, including
but not limited to scholars of
the indigenous North American
experience, history, culture,
religion, spirituality,
society, and politics, and,
by the way, Federal Indian law
in the United States,
that Harvard draw
upon its rich intellectual
and material resources
to examine America's
relationship with indigenous
peoples and the long
history of dispossession,
forcible guardianship, removal,
and compulsory evangelization
in boarding schools,
to say nothing
of institutionalized violence.
And finally, that Harvard do
for its own indigenous history
what Northwestern has
done, what Dartmouth
has done, what Yale and
Brown are now doing,
or what the University of
British Columbia has done,
namely that Harvard do for
its own indigenous history
what Harvard is doing
now, and next year,
including proudly and
appropriately, here
at Radcliffe, in its
commemoration of slavery
and its own relationship
to racial bondage,
to do three things.
A, appoint a
committee to examine
Harvard's own relationship to
Native American dispossession,
B, to offer seminars and courses
in which students can join
with faculty in conducting
research on Harvard's
indigenous history,
painful and even
embarrassing as that
history may be, and C,
to hold a conference,
as Radcliffe,
again, will appropriately
and probably
do on slavery in the
university in March
of 2017, another
conference in the future
on indigenous dispossession
and the university.
Making Harvard whole is
something happening today,
Friday, April 29, in native
peoples doing native politics,
and in the future by
performing native politics
for and by native peoples.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to introduce
Maggie McKinley, who's
the moderator of
our first panel.
Maggie McKinley is a
Climenko Fellow and Lecturer
of Law at Harvard Law School.
She's also from the Fond du Lac
Band of Lake Superior Chippewa.
She writes about legislation,
theories of interpretation,
minority rights
and representation,
and federal Indian law.
And she is the principal
co-investigator
of the Language of Lobbying
Project at the University
of Chicago, and
collaborator with me--
and I'm honored to say that--
with the North American
Petitions Project at the Harvard
Department of Government.
I rarely describe a paper
and essay as brilliant,
but I want to alert you
all to her brilliant essay
coming out in next month's
Stanford Law Review-- it is
next month, right?
It hasn't been postponed--
entitled "Lobbying
and the Petition Clause."
I've been working on
petitioning now for 15 years.
It's the single best
paper in the field.
She's also done thoughtful
work on lobbying
and on federal
Indian law, and she
helped immensely in the
creation of the framework
for this conference.
Having gotten to know her
over the last couple years
has been a privilege
and pleasure.
As I am a student, a
very amateur student
of Native American politics and
Native American petitioning,
it is with frequency but
with patience and kindness
that Maggie often corrects
me on my historical facts
and cultural
misapprehensions, and I
have to admit they are many.
But I am indeed
honored to call her
a colleague, a
collaborator, and a friend.
Maggie McKinley.
-Good morning.
That introduction, in many
ways, completely oversold
what's coming this morning.
But thank you so much,
Dan, for overdoing it.
I'm always grateful for that.
So welcome to our first
panel of the morning.
This is on native law
and legal strategy.
And what you'll notice
first is that we're
missing one of our panelists
to a rogue flu that
hit him this morning.
But we're going to do our
best to muddle through,
and we're grateful for your
patience with the panel.
And we're looking forward
to having more Q&A
with the audience at the end.
So I'd like to start off
by thanking our organizers,
both at Radcliffe-- so
Dean Cohen Becky, Paul--
and at HUNAP, Dennis,
Shelly, and then
there's also Jason and
Sam, way in the back.
Thank you so much for all
of your energy this year.
It's been a pleasure to work
with all of you, and an honor.
I'd like to extend a
very special thanks
to Dan Carpenter, the
political scientist
mastermind behind
our thematic year
of the Performance of Native
Politics Outside the Vote.
We often envision voting
as the primary mechanism
of representation
in a democracy.
So why exactly did we
focus our thematic year
on participation
outside of the vote?
In 1924, Native Americans
were extended the franchise
in federal elections.
You heard me right.
That was 1924.
19.
That was 54 years
after the ratification
of the 15th Amendment, which
outlawed extending the right
to vote on the basis of race.
And it wasn't until 1964 that
natives were given the right
to vote in states like Utah.
In Minnesota, where
my family is from,
the Minnesota
constitution contained
an explicit civilization
clause that required natives
to pass a civilization test
before a district judge
before being able to vote
in Minnesota elections.
This means that for a majority
of this nation's history,
over 150 years, Native
Americans were excluded
from the primary mechanism
of representation
in our government.
Our tribal governments
still have no formal means
of representation in our
federal and state systems.
We've had to find ways to
advocate for our sovereignty
elsewhere.
Luckily for our communities,
sovereignty is like water,
and when one channel
is closed, it
flows into whatever
channels are open to it.
We'll hear later today about
efforts aimed at Congress
and the Executive
Branch, and also efforts
aimed at the public
through art and mass media.
But we'd like to start
first with the courts.
This is the site where
the United States first
articulated the famous words,
domestic dependent nations,
and in so doing
named what some call
federal recognition
of tribal sovereignty,
and what others--
not so friendly--
call a legal fiction.
In many ways, the
story of native America
within the courts
is a familiar one.
Like many other
disenfranchised, discrete,
and insular minorities,
natives took to the courts
during the Civil
Rights era to bring
the tools of impact litigation
to bear on the problems
that the electoral branches
just would not solve.
Like Brown v. Board, Roe v.
Wade, and Romer v. Evans,
natives saw some
successes in the courts.
But the native story
is also distinctive.
Unlike the traditional liberal
integrationist approach
of other minority
groups, natives
enjoyed structural
protection as minorities
through sovereignty and
local self-governments,
and not simply
through the protection
of constitutional rights.
Over time the courts have
become increasingly hostile
to the structural protection.
Not only is it something foreign
to other minority groups,
the court began to
see native sovereignty
as something that was actually
in tension with the rights
of others, mostly the
rights of non-Indians
within Indian country.
Rather than rights
saving minorities
from the local
control of federalism,
as we often hear in our
oversimplified story
of the Warren Court and
the Civil Rights era,
we've seen a much more
nuanced relationship
between natives and the courts.
It's this more
nuanced relationship
that our panel explores today.
And to foster that
discussion, we'll
begin with someone
that I like to think
of as the conductor of the
National Symphony of Indian law
litigation, Richard Guest, Staff
Attorney the Native American
Rights Fund and head of its
Tribal Supreme Court Project,
and in full disclosure,
my former boss.
If there's a single case
in the entire United
States and elsewhere that's
important to Indian country,
I have no doubt that
Richard knows about it
and is organizing everything
around it already.
And we'll also hear from the
Honorable Diane Humetewa,
United States District Judge
for the District of Arizona,
citizen of the Hopi
Nation, and the very first
Native American woman
appointed to the Federal bench.
Please join me in
welcoming our panel.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you, Maggie.
It is a pleasure to
be with you all today
and to be a part of an
important dialogue that's
been long in coming to
this part of the country.
The conversation has
taken place elsewhere,
but certainly it's
necessary here.
My role today is to come to you
from the Native American Rights
Fund, NARF, as we
refer to ourselves.
HUNAP, NARF, you
get all the acronyms
once you start coming to
Indian law conferences.
Have to figure this out.
And as has already been alluded
to in the remarks this morning,
the movements
throughout this century
ultimately led to the formation
of the Native American Rights
Fund.
It was really as a part
of the work of the NAACP
LDF, the Legal Defense Fund,
that the concept came out,
through the California
Indian Legal Services,
for the need for a
National Indian law firm,
that there would be a
nonprofit established that
would undertake the work
of national litigation
on behalf of Indian tribes
and individual Indians.
And so NARF was established.
David Getches, Charles
Wilkinson, John Echo Hawk,
my current executive director,
were all there in 1970.
And they decided that the
location for the Native
American Rights Fund needed
to be at a neutral site,
because Indian country
out in the West
is captured by various
interests, much like now,
here in the east and
in the south, where
if you're in the southwest,
you have particular interests
for particular tribes,
if you're in California,
if you're in the Northwest,
if you're in the plains.
And so they made a
conscious decision
to locate in Boulder,
Colorado, just right
off the campus of the
University of Colorado,
and that was in 1970.
I'm not going to
read my PowerPoint.
I'll let you do that.
But when NARF was established
through its indigenous board
of directors, they determined
that there would be five goals,
and it became our
mission statement.
The preservation
of tribal existence
and the protection of
tribal natural resources
became paramount.
Again, throughout
much of history,
Native Americans survived by
being invisible to the majority
population.
That being invisible
meant you didn't even
know they were there,
and that was a survival
tactic, because if you knew
they were there, that they had
lands, that they had
goods, Indians learned,
you'd take them away.
And so they very much
lived life under the radar.
The protection of
tribal natural resources
has been a primary
mission of NARF.
We have been involved in almost
every major piece of litigation
involving water rights and the
protection and preservation
of tribal resources that
mean survival for the tribes.
We're also engaged
in the preservation
of Native American human
rights, the accountability
of governments to
Native Americans,
and one of our major roles
in the past number of years
has been the development
of Indian law
and the education of the public.
So I lay that out there
just as a framework
to do to be thinking that
back in 1970, leaders
from throughout Indian
country came together
with lawyers to talk about how
best to serve Indian country.
One of my basic
presentations, just about
the sources of federal
Indian law-- and I
do this at Indian law
conferences with lawyers
all the time, because we need
to be reminded that there
are sources for
federal Indian law,
for the establishment through
these various mediums.
Under the US Constitution
we have the Treaty Clause
formulated under
international law
with military and
foreign affairs policy.
And for us, we view that
not as a grant of authority,
but as a reservation of rights
under the US Constitution.
There's the Indian
Commerce Clause,
and much has been written
around this particular clause.
And the Supremacy
Clause, which I
like to read,
Article VI, Clause 2,
"The Constitution and the laws
of the United States which
shall be made in pursuance
thereof, and all treaties made,
or which shall be made, under
the authority of the United
States, shall be the
Supreme Law of the Land."
So we move from the
Constitution to federal statutes
and regulations.
Many of you may
know or may not know
that there's an entire title
of the US Code dedicated
to the regulation of
Indian people, Title 25.
Indian people are perhaps the
most highly regulated people
on the planet, and
it comes into play
with our interactions
in the courts
and through the
administrative agencies
and through Congress, which
you'll hear about later.
Then we have the
development of common law
through the federal courts.
And I think that that is
a topic that we'll get
into more in my presentation.
And then I like to remind
folks that similar to what
Dean Cohen talked
about, there were
specific periods in the
development of Indian law
that many Indian law
professors adhere to.
And they talk about
the formative years
from the founding of
the United States.
Well, Indian tribes were
here before the formation
of the United
States, but we talk
about those formative years,
and this is a development
of federal Indian law.
We have the Allotment
and Assimilation Era.
And again, this was
an era where there
were many well-meaning
non-Indians who
believed that this
was in the best
interests of Indian
people, that by breaking up
their reservation and giving
lands to individual Indians
and assimilating them
into the mainstream,
that we were doing
right by Indians.
And the exact opposite
was the truth.
And in 1928, there was a
report issued called The Miriam
Report, and it detailed the
poverty and the suffering that
was occurring throughout
Indian country
as a result of allotment
and assimilation.
And thus we come into
the Indian Reorganization
Era with the passage of
Act in 1934, where the
Congress made a determination
that the future
for Indians meant
allowing their
governments to reorganize.
They saw them, and again
created constitutions
for tribal governments
in which to govern
on their reservations.
They stopped the
process of allotment
through the Indian
Reorganization Act.
The whole idea of
allotment was to break up
the Indian reservations,
destabilize
a central form of
government, and thereby take
care of the Indian problem,
that Indians would just be
absorbed into the mainstream.
But guess what?
Indians didn't want to be
absorbed into the mainstream.
They wanted to maintain
their identity.
They wanted to maintain their
culture and their traditions.
traditional ways of life,
because that's who they were.
So we enter into an era where
there's a real conflict,
where again, well-meaning,
well-intentioned non-Indians
are saying, here's
a solution for you,
instead of looking to the
tribes, to the Indians,
and saying, what do you want?
So we have this era of
self-determination, the Indian
Reorganization Act.
I'm getting ahead of
myself, but there was also
that same force that existed
within the United States
government that continued
to see Indians as a problem,
and they continued to seek
that the best way to help
Indians was to terminate
the federal relationship
with the tribes.
And there are examples from
around Indian country of that
occurring, and again,
the devastating
impacts, where tribes
had been successful
in the use of the
natural resources.
One of NARF's clients is the
Klamath Tribes in Oregon,
and they were one
of the leaders.
They had huge timber resources.
They were living a high quality
of life on their reservation,
engaged with the non-Indian
communities around them,
with the state of Oregon.
And in the 19050s,
the federal government
saw them as a success, that they
didn't need federal supervision
anymore, cut the ties,
broke up the reservation,
and the tribe almost
immediately fell off a cliff
to where they experienced
the loss of who
they were as a people.
They were no longer
successful economically,
that again, it was an area
where we could talk and do
an entire conference
on the termination
policies and its impacts.
As we move forward,
there's the famous speech
in 1972 that
President Nixon gave,
The Indian
Self-Determination Act, where
he recognized and Congress
ultimately passed-- I never
get the name right anymore,
The Indian Education
Self-Determination, or Indian
Self-Determination Education
Assistance Act.
We refer to it as
630A contracting
of opening up opportunities
for tribal governments
to take on programs that
were once administered
by the federal government
on behalf of the tribes,
and give them the
financial resources
to run those government
programs themselves
in all different kinds of
areas regarding governance.
Now we come to talk
about the work that I do,
the Supreme Court Project, and
my colleague, John Dossett, who
you hear from later from The
National Congress of American
Indians.
Prior to 1978, and
really into the 1980s,
Indian tribes were having
great success in the courts.
When NARF was founded
in 1970, we immediately
brought a number of
pieces of litigation,
in particular,
under the treaties.
There were the
great fishing wars
that were taking
place in Washington
and Oregon and Michigan.
And fishing rights
and hunting rights
were one of those rights
expressly preserved
under the treaties
with the United States.
There were land claims happening
here in the east coast.
And NARF was, along with
others, bringing those claims
into the federal courts and
having levels of success.
But back in 1978, there was
a justice, at that time,
on the Supreme Court,
William Rehnquist,
who had a different
vision for Indian tribes,
who really was a deeply
committed states'
rights activist, who
really is committed to,
or was committed to, an ideal
that no one has special rights.
No one in this country
has special rights.
We're all the same.
So again, I don't believe
that it was necessarily
started as animus
against Indian people,
but his own commitment
to his own ideals,
that he crafted the
opinion in Oliphant, which
was an Indian law case
involving criminal jurisdiction
over non-Indians
on the reservation.
And the rule came out
of Oliphant, something
known as implicit divestiture.
And what that means is
although it's not explicit,
there's no way that the United
States would have bargained
for Indian tribes having
authority over non-Indians
and being able to criminally
prosecute them even though they
commit crimes
within their lands,
and even though
under the treaties
that the United States had
entered into with tribes,
that they actually
say that tribes
would have this authority.
So implicitly, the
Indian tribes were
divested of that authority.
William Rehnquist went on
to become Chief Justice.
And then we start
seeing the period,
now, what I described
in the earlier slide
as possibly the period
of judicial termination,
where through the courts, the
United States is achieving,
or opponents to Indian
country in the exercise
of inherent tribal
authority are achieving
a level of success
of terminating
those rights and the
exercise of those rights.
So during the October term 2000,
there were a number of cases--
and please let me know.
Write it down if
I'm taking too long.
In 2000, there were
a number of cases
that came down, in
particular, Atkinson Trading,
dealing with a
tax on non-Indians
in a hotel situated
on the Navajo Indian
reservation located on fee
land owned by the hotel,
but surrounded by
reservation trust land,
receiving services
from the Navajo Nation,
but feeling that they should
not be subject to the hotel tax.
And then we also
had Nevada v. Hicks,
which involved state officials
coming onto the reservation
to execute search warrants for
the illegal hunting of big horn
sheep off reservation,
but within the hunting
grounds of the tribe.
We were successful in both
cases in the lower courts.
We had won judgments in
favor of no state authority
in Hicks, yes to tribal
authority in Atkinson Trading.
We end up in front of
the US Supreme Court,
and we get two decisions
adverse to Indian country.
And it shook up a number of
leaders, because at that time,
there were a number of other
efforts underway in the media,
at Congress, that were
truly anti-Indian.
And so a meeting was
called in Washington, DC,
on September 11, 2001.
And the National
Tribal Leadership all
came in on that day to meet.
Senator Inouye was
there, and as you know,
had to excuse himself
because planes had just flown
into the World Trade Center.
And then a plane flew
into the Pentagon.
The silver lining to
that very dark cloud
was the fact that we
had a captive audience
of tribal leaders
in Washington, DC.
And so through that came what
was known as The Sovereignty
Protection Initiative,
initiative by the National
Tribal Leadership to preserve
tribal sovereignty in all
respects.
And there were four projects
that were formulated out
of that meeting.
There was the
legislative project
to undo what the court had done
in Oliphant, and subsequently
in the Montana case with
respect to civil jurisdiction,
to address tribal authority
over non-Indians legislatively.
There were also efforts underway
at that time in the Congress
with respect to the
immunity of tribes,
and trying to waive that
immunity so that non-Indians
could sue Indian
tribal governments,
and a host of others.
So those were
initiatives underway,
and there was a
project established
to address legislative fixes,
to ensure full expression
of tribal sovereignty.
Then there was the
media public relations,
addressing it through educating
the public with respect
to that the tribes are here,
they haven't gone anywhere,
they will continue to be here,
and that it's a good thing
that the tribes are still here.
There was the Judicial
Nominations Project, now known
as the NCAI Project
on the Judiciary,
where we worked extremely
hard on identifying
native candidates who were
qualified to serve as judges
on the federal courts prior to
Judge Humetewa'a appointment,
there had only been
two-- in the history
of the federal
bench-- two judges
who were of Native
descent on the bench.
One of them didn't know
he was Native at the time,
that he was appointed
by President Carter.
The other had resigned
his seat shortly
after he was appointed
by President Clinton
to return to private practice.
So for a long period of time,
we had no Native American judges
on the Federal bench.
And we're working
to change that,
and we're working at the
level of the state courts
as well to change
the dynamic there
to make sure that Natives
have an opportunity to serve
on state court benches.
So along with those
three projects,
the Tribal Supreme
Court Project,
a real effort by the
National Tribal Leadership
to address what was
happening in the court, what
they were witnessing
in terms of the erosion
of tribal sovereignty
through the courts.
So the purpose of
the project was
to strengthen tribal
advocacy, do that
through coordinating resources,
developing specific strategies,
creating relationships
and networks.
We have the staff with the
attorneys at the Native
American Rights Fund.
I say attorneys.
There are two of us
who do this work,
and I do it mostly full-time.
Attorneys at the
National Congress
of American Indians, John
Dossett and his colleague Colby
Duren.
And then I now have
a working group.
I have to update this slide.
I'm now up over 300
attorneys, tribal leaders,
and law professors
on our working group.
And our role is multifaceted.
We monitor all the cases
in the lower courts.
We try to identify
trends that are
occurring in the lower courts.
We're trying to
identify cases that we
believe are problematic for us.
If you remember,
the NAACP, when it
was envisioning how to
undo racial segregation,
it brought a series
of targeted cases
that they felt that they
could win all the way up
through the Supreme
Court, culminating
in Brown v. Board of Education.
And there was a
strategy behind that.
The project tries
to emulate that.
We oftentimes cannot bring cases
the way that the NAACP would
bring cases, because cases are
happening all the time without
our input and us being
able to say, bad case,
please don't bring that.
Well, the tribe, the people,
the individual allottees, they
need to have their
rights vindicated,
and they'll use the courts or
whatever sources they have.
So we can't control it.
So we move along
very quickly now
to the role of the work of
the Supreme Court Project.
We keep these cases updated and
we conduct national conference
calls on a regular basis to
talk with the work group members
throughout the country.
The normal things that
a project of this sort
would do in consultation
with the Tribal Leadership,
we work heavily at the search
stage in the Supreme Court,
where a determination is
made whether to grant or deny
review of a particular case.
We have an ongoing relationship
with the United States
Solicitor General's
Office whenever we're
not adverse to them in a case.
And we coordinate
moot courts, and I've
had the pleasure of mooting some
of the most well-known Supreme
Court practitioners who
have been arguing our case,
including Neal Katyal,
who argued the Bay Mills
case and the Dollar
General case,
Paul Clement, who successfully
argued the Nebraska v. Parker
case this term, and
a number of others.
So in just a couple
of minutes, I just
want to kind of cover some of
the work that we've tracked
and give you an idea of
just the breadth of work.
In 2011 we published
our Ten Year Report
for the Supreme Court Project.
And you can see from
the graph the types
of cases that were at court,
where we were petitioning
the court or someone was
petitioning the court,
to decide an issue.
And civil jurisdiction, criminal
jurisdiction, Indian gaming,
lands sort of led the way.
The most litigated issue
was sovereign immunity.
Then you look at the cases
that the court granted,
and you see that
they are dominated
by cases usually brought
by the federal government
or by state governments
against trials.
The trust
responsibility, taxation
were the leading cases.
This graph was to illustrate the
outcomes for tribal interests
in the lower courts.
We'll talk about the
outcomes real quickly
in the Supreme Court.
And on average, we are 50-50.
We win half the time,
we lose half the time
in the lower appellate courts.
So to kind of wrap this
up, our win-loss record
with the Rehnquist court at
the start of the project we
actually improved.
In the beginning
there was a slide
that talked about David
Getches and the loss rate,
that Indian tribes at the
time were winning only 25%
of their cases, one in four.
Our winning percentage
was lower than that
of criminal defendants
in front of the court.
So when we got together
with the Project,
we saw almost immediate success.
There are varying
reasons for that,
but we were four wins,
three losses, two draws.
When the Roberts court
came in, and at the time
of the publication of
the Ten Year Report,
we were zero for seven.
And we had-- partly
because of the retirement
of Justice O'Connor,
Chief Justice Roberts
coming on the court to replace
Chief Justice Rehnquist, Samuel
Alito, who until the
Nebraska v. Parker case,
has never voted in favor
of Indian interests
in a single case.
And now we're starting to take
a look at the more recent terms.
We're now-- with no
decision in two of the cases
at the court today--
we're now two and two.
We had the loss in Patchak,
the win in Ramah Navajo,
the loss in Baby Girl,
the win in Bay Mills.
This term we now have
the loss in Menominee
and the win in
Nebraska v. Parker.
So we're at 50%.
And I haven't had a chance to
break that down and analyze
why, because we were
basically zero for nine,
and all of a sudden
we're not anymore.
So I have to start
crunching that data.
But some things we
have noticed is,
there's been a real decrease
in the number of cert petitions
in Indian law cases
over the recent terms,
and there's been a huge decline
in the number of Indian law
cases granted.
Before the Rehnquist
court, there
was an average of three
to four Indian law cases
heard by the Supreme Court.
During the Rehnquist court,
there was two to three.
With the Roberts court,
it's been one Indian law
case on average.
Now that's changed, and we'll
be taking a look at that.
And this term the number
of Indian law petitions
is back up to its
average of 26, 27.
So there's the presentation.
I hope that there are questions,
and that I did leave time
for us to have that
interaction to dig down
a little bit about this.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
-I was happy to yield
time to you, Richard.
It was very fascinating to me.
Well, I want to begin
first by thinking
Councilman Perry for that
wonderful welcome and blessing
and beautiful song,
and Dean Cohen
for her encouraging
and kind remarks.
My remarks were
to have followed,
I think, a foundational
set of remarks
from our absent presenter.
So if you will bear with
me, I hope that some of this
isn't too general.
But in the time
that we have left,
or the time that I hope to
have left on the program,
we'd love to hear questions.
And I certainly have
questions of my own
for Richard that will
probably go beyond the break.
But what I'm actually
going to talk to you about
builds on a little bit of
what Richard talked about,
but it sort of comes from
a different perspective.
I'm first going to talk about
tribal court systems generally.
And what I mean in terms
of tribal court systems
is really discussing the
rule of law and custom
in those systems, and the
federal government's influence
over those systems.
And I'm going to use
my own Hopi tribal
court, the court that I used
to sit on as an appellate court
judge, as an example.
And then I'm going to talk about
judging within the two systems
that I'm familiar with,
the tribal court system
and now the federal
court system,
sort of give you a comparison
and contrast as to what
I see are similarities and
differences in the role
of a judge in those
systems, and then talk
about the need for
coordination and consultation,
which sort of goes very
nicely with what Richard just
finished discussing.
And I'm going to try to
do that by first laying
a foundation of where I
come from, the Hopi Tribe,
because this is going to
be the example that we're
going to use.
As you can see here,
our reservation area
was established by
executive order in 1882.
How many in the
audience have ever
been to the Hopi Indian Nation?
Oh, gosh.
Probably a quarter
of the audience.
Well, if you can
see on the map, we
are that little brownish area
in Northeastern Arizona that's
surrounded by the blue, and
the blue is the Navajo Nation.
So we are a landlocked
tribe, essentially,
comprised of 12 villages,
which is important for you
to remember as we go
through this discussion.
And you'll see the acreage
in terms of square miles,
and according to our census,
the population of tribally
enrolled members, which, by
the way, has been growing.
Historically we were and still
are a very traditional tribe,
and we are a
matrilineal society,
which is also very important
for our discussion this morning.
And so historically,
you were automatically
a member of the tribe
if your mother was Hopi.
And then because of the
sort of advancements
in the rules of enrollment,
now the current criteria
is you have to have a quarter
lineage of Hopi blood.
And so traditionally,
essentially, we still
follow our mothers' line in
terms of village membership.
Just by notation, the little
small blocks on the map
denote where the other Indian
nations are in Arizona.
There are 22 Indian
nations in Arizona,
two of the largest in
the nation, the Tohono
O'odham, which is to the
south, adjacent to Tucson,
and runs into Mexico, and
of course the Navajo Nation.
Those of you who have been to
Hopi recognize this photograph.
And for some it might be
difficult to make out,
but this is on 2nd Mesa,
the village of Sipaulovi
and Mishongnovi, which are
both on the bottom of the mesa,
and the traditional homes are
on the very top of those two
mesas.
And you can see the
expanse of the homes that
are below the mesas.
And then Highway 264
runs adjacent almost
at the bottom of
this photograph.
We are a very
traditional community.
There is sort of a
modern village photograph
down to the left,
the lower left.
And you can see we still are
a very traditional farming
community.
Basically our existence
revolves around our farming
and the growth of corn,
and our crops of corn
that we use in our ceremonies,
of course, for our sustenance.
And we follow a very
traditional ceremonial cycle,
and we are very well known for
our kachina ceremonies, which
have now become art in terms
of our kachina carvings,
which are primarily done
by the men in our villages.
My village affiliation, I am
from the village of Hotevilla,
which is 3rd Mesa.
And I am a member
of that village.
My grandmother-- my great
grandmother, I should say--
was one of the
families who relocated
from the traditional
village of Old Oraibi, which
the Hopi consider the longest
continuously inhabited
village in the United States.
I think we compete with
Acoma for that label.
But in any event,
my great grandmother
helped to establish--
she was one
of the so-called traditionalists
who moved away from Old Oraibi
to resettle the traditionalists
to different areas on the mesa.
And my family, then, is from
the village of Hotevilla,
which is about six, eight miles
down the road from Mishongnovi.
And I am of the Tobacco Clan.
We say [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
which is essentially
the responsibility of our clan
system is to be caretakers
and provide the tobacco for
all of the ceremonies that are
necessary in our society.
So I want to begin by talking
a little bit about some
of the influences
that Richard mentioned
in terms of our history with
Indian tribes and the Federal
government.
This is how our
constitution looks today.
It is our Constitution
of the Hopi Tribe.
And essentially, this
was enacted in 1936.
And I want to point out the
preamble of our constitution.
As you can read there, it
recognizes the village autonomy
of the Hopi people.
And whenever I
read this preamble,
that the Constitution is adopted
by the self-governing Hopi
and Tewa villages, I
think about what happened
in enacting this Constitution.
First, let me go
to the next slide.
And if you'll see the
first bullet point,
it talks about the Indian
Reorganization Act.
Of these eras that Richard
talked about, we, of course,
were influenced by these eras
in the federal government.
There was a period of time
where the original Spaniards who
came-- the Hopi people
along with the other Pueblo
people in New Mexico fought
off the Spaniard influences,
and that stood for a while.
And then came the
federal government
with all of the
policies of assimilation
and taking the children off
to boarding school and so on,
and then the influx of the
federal officials, the BIA
officials, if you will, who
came into the community.
And then there was
this era of time
where the federal
government said, well,
look, if we just give them
rules or structure of rules,
then they can start
governing themselves.
And so there was this
movement on the Hopi villages.
And if you can imagine
back in the 1930s,
there was still a very
traditional Hopi language
that was predominantly
the language there.
These officials would go
into the kiva chambers,
our ceremonial chambers,
and try to convince
the leaders of our villages
to adopt this Constitution.
And there was a
large back and forth,
and it was a two-year process
of going village to village,
going into the kivas, talking to
the men, getting them to go out
to the communities to say, this
Constitution is a good thing.
And at the end of the day,
when you think about it,
this Constitution was actually
passed by a vote of 104
to the 651 eligible
members to vote.
And so we still
have this struggle
in our community about the
legitimacy of this Constitution
because of the number of people
that actually voted to pass it.
But in any event, what
I think about when
I look at this
preamble is really
the foresight of some of
the elders who participated
in those discussions
to really point out
the autonomy of the very
villages from which they came
and the role of the villages
in Hopi society generally.
This Constitution establishes
the tribal government.
It essentially is a
one-branch government.
And that's necessary
to also remember
because it does not establish,
like our Constitution,
a three-tiered
branch of government.
Oh, I'm going backwards.
So moving forward
to our establishment
of our tribal court systems.
You can see there that
we also fell influence
to the code of federal offenses.
Essentially what
occurred-- how many of
you know where the
Bureau of Indian Affairs
developed out of?
War Department.
So during these various
eras of assimilation,
you did have the necessity
for these Indian agents
to do something to bring
these native people in line.
And so what happened was,
they established these courts.
And the courts were really
made up of ad hoc rules.
And the ad hoc
rules of punishing
Indians who weren't coming
in line with what the desired
federal policy of
the day was, ad hoc
rules to deal with the
traditionalists, in our case,
at Hopi, who refused to
have their children taken
to boarding school.
How do you deal
with these folks who
are disrupting the forward
movement of the government?
And so oftentimes
what would happen is,
the BIA superintendent
would appoint
a person, a friendly Indian,
to be a judge on these courts.
And in our case, you can see
here that the CFR court in Hopi
was established in 1940.
It was essentially
the BIA superintendent
who told an individual, here's
the code of federal rules.
Read this book and apply it to
the cases that come before you.
And in many instances,
a lot of the cases
that were first heard in the CFR
courts were criminal matters.
And if it was interesting.
I was reading some of
the former documents,
and the judge, the
first CFR judge,
basically said, well,
I'll read this book,
and I'll just apply it
until the Hopi people know
what this court is about.
SO I thought that was
kind of interesting.
So jumping forward, the CFR
court, then, was in operation.
And again, it only predominantly
worked on criminal matters.
And there was an
assumption in the community
that the other matters, the more
civil matters, the things that
involved family,
were all being taken
care of at the local level.
And when I was an
appellate court judge,
I found it very, very
interesting to learn
that our Hopi court
was established almost
in an ad hoc
manner, if you will.
There was a lawsuit
that was brought
by a Navajo man
against the Hopi tribe
because his livestock
had been taken.
They had gone over into
a Hopi land grazing area.
And the non-Indian
lawyer at the time
convened a meeting of the
existing tribal council.
And there was a discussion
about what do we do?
How do we address this issue?
And there was only
a small paragraph
that then describes a
vote to establish a court
system in 1972.
And so out of this
sort of reaction, then,
comes this is what we call
Ordinance 21, which is,
today, our ordinance that
establishes our Hopi court.
One of the interesting things
that occurred a couple years
later is that the Hopi
council, in their wisdom,
passed a resolution, H-1276,
that requires the tribal court
to apply custom, tradition,
and culture in deciding matters
of both substance and procedure.
And that resolution actually
establishes the foundations
of how the Hopi
appellate court applies
custom and law in current cases
that come before it today.
I also wanted to point
out this provision.
And I don't know if you
can read that up there.
But this is actually a
section of the Constitution,
Article III, that talks
about the organization,
the acknowledgement
of the villages
that were established
at the time.
But what I wanted to point
out here is Section 2.
It basically reserves
to those villages
certain types of decision
making to appoint guardians
for orphan children, to
adjust family disputes
and regulate family
relationships,
to assign farming land and
property and inheritance.
Again, another very thoughtful
and deliberate statement
that basically says, we
preserve these rights
to our individual villages.
And so this, actually,
also provides
a basis for our tribal courts.
When primarily
addressing civil issues,
many of these civil issues--
in particular, property
and inheritance-- are
sent back to the villages
for a first decision.
And if the village doesn't
want to get involved
in that decision,
they have to certify
that to go up to the court
to let the court exercise
its jurisdiction
over that matter.
But what has happened
over time is,
those various provisions
that I pointed out
have established a very
interesting practice
and procedure in the Hopi court.
That is, because tradition
and custom oftentimes
aren't known and may never be
known by certain individuals,
especially if you're not in a
particular society that needs
to know, it created a quandary.
So in the late
'90s, early 2000s,
the Hopi appellate court,
before I was on it,
established a system to
develop that customary law.
And the way that was created
was sort of happenstance.
It resulted as a
property dispute,
and the tribal judge
took it upon himself
to go to the village,
hear from elders
about how property
was distributed
in that particular
village and in that clan,
and then heard from
elders in the family,
and they developed
this body of law.
And it was through that system
that that became precedent
and process and procedure.
And again, those
procedures are used today.
What that has developed,
however, is a tension.
Because I've talked primarily
about the custom and tradition
in civil types of
cases, family cases.
But we still have
essentially a reversion back
to the CFR courts in
criminal practice.
And there it's very difficult,
because you have individuals
who are asserting due
process rights that
flow from the United
States Constitution
and the Bill of Rights.
And you have an adversarial
system on the one hand.
And oftentimes, that adversarial
system in the criminal process
flows into the civil process.
It does that in particular
situations where
you have individual
judges, frankly,
who are used to
that sort of system.
They revert back to the
systems that they're used to.
Oftentimes they come
from state courts,
or county courts, city courts,
who come out to practice law.
And so there's this
tension between how
do you adhere to the
common practices of custom
and tradition in resolving
interfamily disputes,
and still pay attention
to the individual right?
So I will tell you that
there are these tensions that
have developed, because
of course our societies,
like many tribal
societies, are changing.
And so people value their goods,
people value their property.
And one of the
areas that started
to emerge when I left
the court back in 2007
was the introduction of
the concept of wills.
Well, if you have this body of
traditional and customary law
that addresses property
distribution, especially
homesteads, agricultural,
farming land, livestock grazing
areas, and you have
individuals who have grown up
in today's society who have
been taught that ownership,
property, possession
is a valued thing,
the two are always going
to come in tension.
There's this tension
that's automatically
built in to the argument.
So those are some
of the struggles
that I think the modern day
courts are going to deal with.
I want to move really
quickly and sort of talk
about the role of judging.
As you can see here, in
the Hopi tribal court,
it is a unilateral
system of government.
There are only two court
systems, the trial court
and the appellate court, and
the ultimate decision maker
is the Tribal Council.
But I have yet to see the
tribal council overturn
an appellate court decision.
The tribes, like many tribes
throughout the United States,
they have broad
civil jurisdiction
to address things that
occur to the extent
that it hasn't been eroded,
as Richard well knows.
There is still limited
criminal jurisdiction
as a result of the Major Crimes
Act, the Assimilative Crimes
Act, Oliphant, Duro
versus Reina decisions.
And tribal judges primarily,
on the Hopi court,
have to wear the hat of a
mediator, an arbitrator,
and ultimately a decision
maker, in many instances.
But in the US Court
system, as you know,
it's very circumscribed.
We have the Supreme
Court precedent
that we have to apply.
We have, in my case, the
Ninth Circuit precedent
that you have to apply.
We are limited
jurisdiction courts,
so we only can hear
matters of diversity
over a particular amount,
a constitutional question.
We are very rule-
and process-oriented.
And of course, we are always
subject to appellate review,
whereas in the Hopi
instance, as I mentioned,
the ultimate decision maker
is the Hopi Tribal Council.
And so the issues in
being a tribal court
judge versus a
federal court judge
are really very different.
In the tribal court systems,
when I was an appellate court
judge, you really had
to balance thinking
about the preservation of
custom and tradition because
of its impact not just to
the individual case, or even
the individual claim, but
beyond that, the impact
to the society in the
particular village or the clan,
and the existence of the
Hopi tribe as a whole.
In the federal courts, I
would say, in many instances,
it's much easier,
because you're only
focused on the case
in front of you,
only focused on the
individual's rights and claims.
And the law, for the
most part, will guide you
as to how the outcome should be.
And so in some very real
ways, tribal judging
is very difficult in
comparison to judging
in state or federal courts.
I want to end by talking about
some of what Richard mentioned.
And this has to do with
the coordinated need
for examining, consulting,
and coordinating discussions
and understanding of the
role of federal courts
in Indian communities.
I think back to my experiences
as both a lawyer in the Senate
Indian Affairs Committee, as
a US attorney for the District
of Arizona, and now as a judge.
And one of the observations
I have always made--
and I'm glad to see that
the tide has changed
with organizations such as NARF
and the Supreme Court Project.
But for the longest time,
and as a very young lawyer,
I was always in federal court.
And I knew in our
courthouse there
were a variety of issues being
discussed that directly impact
if not an Indian family, but
activity in Indian communities.
And frankly, there
were very few times
when I would see tribal
leaders, Indian individuals,
organizations, appearing
at those arguments.
And it always dawned
on me that there
needed to be some
attention paid to what
was going on in these courts.
And so as the US Attorney,
one of the policies
that I implemented in my office
was that every Indian country
case, we were going to transmit
the outcome in a short press
release to the tribal
nation that it involved.
And it was an
interesting comment
that I received from one
of the tribal leaders
that we were meeting with
shortly after the policy began.
And he said, you
know, you've really
created a dilemma for us.
And I said, well,
I don't understand.
He goes, you know those press
releases that you send out?
He said, we really don't
know what to do with them.
The tribal council sometimes
wants to put them out
to the community, and
sometimes they don't.
And so we're debating that.
And I thought, well, at
least they're debating it.
So they understood the
reach of the federal court
in their community.
That was my goal.
And I don't know that
that's being done today.
But one of the things
I think about often,
on the federal
bench, every day we
receive a bulletin from the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals.
And it's remarkable
the number of cases
involving Indian community.
I, of course, am in the Ninth
Circuit, Arizona, California,
Alaska, Washington, Idaho,
all along that western edge
of the United States.
And our federal
court systems today
are being asked
to examine what it
means to be an Indian,
in the Bryant case just
argued in the Supreme Court
about a week and a half ago.
I'm seeing decisions from
the Ninth Circuit courts,
district courts in California,
about claims of disenrollment
in various tribes.
Federal courts are being asked
to answer those questions.
Federal courts are being
involved in disputes
about gaming between tribes.
It just goes on and on.
Water rights, breach
of contract when
tribal governments
enter into contracts
with non-Indian entities.
So I think that in future,
these cases will only increase.
And the need to at least
talk about and understand
the reach of federal courts
in Indian communities,
and the impact to tribal
members, is really important.
And so I want to applaud
NARF and the work
that Richard and John and
others are doing on that level.
So I think I've
gone over my time,
and I'd like to just end there.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you so very much to our
panelists for THAT incredibly
rich discussion of
tribal courts, state
courts, federal courts,
and Indian law generally.
I'd like to open it up for
audience questions now.
And as Dean Cohen mentioned,
though, the custom at Radcliffe
is there is a microphone
positioned in that center
aisle.
So if you have a question,
please collect your thoughts
and bring yourself up
to that microphone.
And I can see a line is forming.
And if you could start
by-- oh, a wonderful line.
If you could start by
introducing yourself
and then by asking
your question.
And all panelists here will
try and take a swing at it.
But thank you so much for all
of this amazing participation.
I'm so glad to see this has
generated so many questions.
-Hello.
My name is Kelly Dennis.
I'm from the Shinnecock
tribe across the water.
I'm actually here with my
cousin [? Tiala ?] and Matt.
We drove all night to get
here, also a tribe member.
And also my cousin
[INAUDIBLE] is also here,
and she's more fortunate
that she's more local.
And we're also from
the [INAUDIBLE] tribe
out here in Grafton,
Massachusetts.
So on behalf of all us, we want
to say [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
to the panelists and to you,
and also [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
welcome everyone.
And [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], hello.
So my question's, I
guess, to Richard Guest.
Well, first of all,
thank you, Richard,
so much for being the counsel
of record on our land claim
petition to the Supreme Court.
It's been a huge endeavor
and we definitely
couldn't have done it
without NARF helping us.
My cousin and I
also, we're attorneys
working for the
tribe, and then we
have our nonprofit
that we're continuing
to do work for the tribe.
And so my question,
first, is, I don't
know if you really
touched on current events
with the passing
of Justice Scalia
and how that may affect
the current court
decisions at the
Supreme Court level
with potential Native
American cases.
And also in the case that
President Obama, his nominee
Judge Garland is able to get
placed in the Supreme Court,
if you see any potential
impacts happening there.
And then also another question
is, I really appreciate
the overview of the
Indian Reorganization Act
and the Constitution
that has pretty much been
imposed on tribes.
And what's kind of
been the unfortunate
trend is that we do, with
the native communities,
want to be able to still
reflect our traditional values.
And yet we tend
to still, anyway,
adopt these IRA-looking
constitutions with just one
tribal council because
that just seems to be
the thing that everyone has.
But I was wondering if you might
be able to give some insight as
to a path to constitutional
reform for IRA Constitution
tribes, to Diane.
Thank you so much
for your question.
I just want to make
a quick executive
decision because
we're low on time
and there is quite the line.
I'm wondering if we could
collect a few questions,
and then the panel will address
them en masse, or selectively.
So thank you very much.
If the next person
could come on.
-Hello, my name is Irene Bedard.
I'm President CEO of Sleeping
Lady Films, Waking Giants
Productions, and I'm going
to be on a panel later.
I actually have two questions.
The recent VAWA reauthorization
also included some, I guess,
jurisdictional rights over
non-Native individuals.
And I wondered how that is
playing out in the Tribal Law
and Order Act, along with
another question I have
about our international
sovereignty
rights that came up with
the World Indigenous Forum
semi-recently, and how
that is affecting some
of our international status.
Thank you.
-Good morning.
My name is Rosalind LaPier.
I teach at the
University of Montana
in the Environmental
Studies department.
But I've also worked
for the past 25 plus
years with Native
language revitalization.
So my question is
related to NALA.
So that's the Native
American Languages
Act that was passed in 1990.
Part of the
provisions of NALA was
to allow for native children
to basically do three things.
One is to express themselves
in their native languages,
to be educated in
their native languages,
and to also be assessed
in their native languages.
So the past 25
plus years there's
been a group of native
language schools
that has been working on
the third piece, which is
assessment, and that's testing.
People who are part
of the native language
revitalization
movement have been
working towards having the
federal government allow
tribes and communities
to assess or test
in their own native languages.
So the question
is, how can we get
NALA, which is a policy
that already exists,
it's already on the books, don't
need to create a new policy.
How can we get it implemented,
fully implemented,
across the board?
And how do we get the USDE--
USDE to implement that policy?
-Hi.
My name is Leland [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a community member
in Los Angeles County.
And I'm also part of
the ICWA Task Force
there, the Indian Child
Welfare Act task force there.
And I also was part of
the Baby Veronica case,
an adult adoptee, the
amicus brief there.
And I'm also Navajo in
Santo Domingo pueblo.
And my question is regarding
more along the adoption
line and the foster care
line, such as the Lexi
case, the Alexandria P. Case
that happened in Los Angeles
County recently.
And I would like, I guess,
from a judge's perspective--
so this is more
for you-- what you
think about these cases
coming within your district
since you are part of
the Ninth District.
And also, I guess, the
gentleman's, his perspective
as far as how they
kind of go along there.
So that's kind of my
wonderment, I guess.
Thank you.
-So we're going to--
that was quite the list.
We're going to try and give
a few answers to these,
and hopefully we'll have a
bit more time at the end.
I think they might just be on.
-They might be on.
Why don't you go ahead,
Judge, and talk about ICWA,
or any of them.
-Well, I did want to mention,
and I failed to mention,
that I am aware of the
provisions in the Tribal Law
and Order Act and the
Violence Against Women Act.
And the Tribal Law
and Order Act provides
an opportunity for
tribes to expand
into having federal
criminal authorities up
to a certain extent,
essentially doing
a bit more beyond the
Indian Civil Rights
Act, which requires
tribes only to implement
a one-year penalty.
And the Tribal Law and
Order Act provides tribes,
if they meet certain
criteria, which
are predominantly due
process, right to be heard,
the right to be represented
by legal counsel,
and judges who are law
trained, and a number
of other certifications, if
you will, or requirements.
And about, which I'm not
all that familiar with,
also provides an opportunity for
tribes to essentially-- well,
I should say, for the
federal government
to use tribal convictions
related to domestic violence
or partner abuse.
It's essentially a
three strikes provision
that the federal prosecutor
can use those prior convictions
as a basis for a federal
charge of domestic violence.
And that is currently one of the
cases that is being considered
by the Supreme Court is what
those prior tribal court
convictions have to look like.
And so I do know that there
are a couple of tribes,
one particular in Arizona,
the Pascua Yaqui Tribe,
which is a quote, VAWA certified
tribe, which essentially--
basically it operates like
a municipal court or a city
court.
Everything looks like if you
walked into the Pasqua Yaqui,
except that you're on
the tribe's nation land--
it looks like a city court.
So they're exercising
that jurisdiction.
I know that Hopi, back in 2011,
voted to adopt the Tribal Law
and Order provisions.
And what that did, really,
was it created some tension,
because the Hopi tribe
used to have the ability
to have non-lawyer
judges who spoke
Hopi, who were well-versed
in custom and tradition.
And now a number of
those individuals
have to be replaced
by law trained judges.
And of course, being
as small as we are,
there aren't a whole
lot of law trained
Hopi who are willing to
be judges in Hopi court.
And so there's a bit
of a tension going on.
And so I think that, depending
on what type of court
you come from or what kind
of community you come from,
those communities do have
to make the decision whether
or not to change
their existing models
to meet the requirements of
[? Taloa ?] and the Violence
Against Women Act.
That's the only thing
I'll say about that,
and maybe Richard has
something to say about it.
-Well, I would start
with the first questions
that were put out.
Scalia not being on the
court, a good thing.
I won't say his death
was a good thing.
I was nowhere Near West
Texas on February 13.
But it was a good thing.
We're hoping what would
have been potentially
a landmark Indian law case
in the Dollar General case
would have fundamentally changed
the way in which tribes have
authority over
non-Indians who do
harm on Indian reservations
to Indian people
would've changed with
Scalia on the court.
I firmly believe that.
With his absence, were
hoping for a four-four split
and an affirmance of the
lower appellate court.
With respect to Garland,
jury's still out.
He was not good for us at the
DC Circuit, generally speaking,
a specific case in particular
I won't get into, but one that
an issue that's going to be up
at the Supreme Court next year
more than likely.
Two cert petitions
pending on those issues.
And there is a whole effort.
Although a tribe maybe
under an IRA constitution,
there are opportunities today.
Tribes can reform
their constitutions.
They have that authority.
They don't need to
rely on the BIA.
The BIA has actually, I
believe, removed that provision
that requires tribes to go
seek their approval if they've
adopted an IRA constitution.
However, it's very difficult
to do in the community
because there are vested rights
now in particular families
within the tribal
communities with respect
to making any changes.
With WAWA authorization
and native languages,
I would defer to John
Dossett in the next panel
to revisit those
questions in terms
of where we are with the
implementation of both
of those.
I would tell you that during
the Dollar General argument,
Justice Kennedy was very
forceful in his questions
slash remarks, where he
was asking the advocates,
where does Congress
get this authority?
He wasn't asking, where
do Indian tribes get
this authority to exercise
jurisdiction over non-Indians,
but where would Congress
get this authority
to extend jurisdiction,
whether it
be criminal or civil or other?
So it's something
we're exploring,
we're examining to see where
it might be going with that.
And then thank you
for your contribution
with the Baby Veronica case.
That had to be one of the
most disappointing outcomes.
The statute was clear.
The discussion by
Justice Alito of blood
quantum in the very first
paragraph of his opinion,
very, very disturbing.
As Judge Humetewa said,
what we're seeing now
in the courts is, we're
getting back to a place
where the discussion is about
who's an Indian, you know?
This was what the discussion
was back in the 1930s and 1940s.
Who are Indian tribes?
We had a disturbing decision
at the Supreme Court
in the Carcieri case, after
Governor Carcieri Rhode Island,
that may influence
outcomes down the line
if we don't get a
legislative fix, that
really addressed that question.
Who's an Indian?
Who gets to decide
who's an Indian?
What's an Indian tribes?
Are those Indian
tribes really sovereign
if they're put together of
different groups of Indians
onto a reservation, and we call
it a confederation of tribes?
What real authority is there?
And there's been this dynamic
within the United States
government, like I said before,
between self-determination
and termination.
It still exists inside
the federal government.
It hasn't gone anywhere.
It's just underneath
the surface.
-So we are incredibly
grateful for all
of the audience
participation and interest,
but we are out of time.
So join me in thanking our
panelist, and thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]